My kids have never eaten Mac and cheese before,
so I figured it was time to make them some.
Between business calls and meetings,
I only had a brief period of time to make the pasta,
so I use this opportunity to get my dough started.
I'm using iron corn, the most primitive form of wheat
that's known to be tolerable to those with gluten intolerances.
It's glyphosate and GMO free,
and it's regeneratively farmed by a family in Idaho.
I'm rolling dough in a little balls,
then dropping them into my pasta attachment,
which gives me fresh whole grain elbow pasta.
It's a quick, non stop process that gives me several cups worth.
After finishing with the pasta making,
I leave them to dry in a dishcloth
while I run out to pick my kids up from school.
When we get back home,
I create the cheese sauce with a combination of sharp cheddar
and Parmesan oregano cheeses.
The cheese sauce is slowly thickened by drizzling and raw milk
while stirring constantly.
This process doesn't take long,
and midway through, I add my fresh elbow pasta to a pot of salted
boiling water to cook for four to five minutes until all done.
Tea I add the grated cheeses,
a pinch of salt, and the cooked macaroni pasta to the saucepan.
I stir to combine well
and then dish up each of my children a bowl of macaroni and cheese
for their after school snack.